[Music]
welcome back everyone well what is
happening to the housing market and are
we heading for a crash
i spoke to a local real estate expert to
find out more
all right jared thank you so much for
speaking with me today
thank you for the opportunity to join
you so let's talk
the housing market i i've been hearing
from everyone it's a seller's market
it's a seller's market what can you tell
us are we heading towards a crash or are
we heading towards a housing bubble
you know that's a fantastic question
appreciate you asking that
the simple and straight answer is no
absolutely not
but i'm going to dive in real quick just
to kind of explain how we get to that
answer
because uh while people are kind of
scared about you know the last 10 years
or whatever
what we do know is that when we look at
all of the homes nationwide
that have equity 38 of those have
absolutely no mortgage
another 18 percent have less than 50
percent
on their mortgage meaning they have 50
equity in their house that's almost 60
percent
of the homes who have no reason to walk
away from their home
so you tie that with supreme buyer
demand
extraordinary rates and then super
limited inventory
uh right now buyers are more than
qualified to get into a house
and they have every reason to move in
people are getting married they're
having kids they're doing all the right
things and they're qualifying for it so
no we're not going anywhere near a crash
or a bubble at this time
okay neither one all right and then um i
can we can see our home's value
online you know there are all these
websites we constantly check personally
with our home
um why would you suggest someone not
sell
their home on their own yeah and it
seems like a logical question right i
can take care of it myself
what you're seeing on those websites are
estimates check the fine print they
always say
this is just an estimate for true value
reach out to a professional what we do
as realtors is
we're going to match the near exact
match to the property
and get you a what the current market is
asking for and based on current
conditions
what we can most likely get for you uh
when we can when you compare the cost of
using a realtor typically between three
to seven percent
against the some of those estimated
sites
you're gonna actually leave money on the
table by using them more than likely
anywhere between three to like
five percent money on the table simply
because they're trying to get it at a
lower price than everybody else so
you need an opinion definitely reach out
to a realtor they can absolutely help
you with that information
yeah you educated person in your corner
um i agree with that and so
should we wait for the rates to drop
until we decide to do anything with our
home buy or sell
short answer absolutely not i mean rates
basically follow the strength of the
economy we've got the vaccine rollout
that's doing really well we've got lower
number of coveted cases happening people
are being more responsible publicly
all of that's going to contribute to a
better economy as the economy improves
rates are going to go up that's a
natural reflex in fact if rates go any
further
we probably have a bigger problem on our
hands so uh we expect rates to be at
three percent or so by the end of the
year
now is the best time and keep in mind we
are at historic lows so even if it goes
up another point or two
we're still having the best experience
on our rate on the rates right now so
take advantage of what you got jared
also explained that you don't need
perfect credit to buy a home if you have
a fico score of 580 or more you can get
into a home yes with higher rates but
you can qualify
his recommendation get your score to 660
or higher and of course
palacios realty is always there to help
you with answers to any of your
questions so make sure to give them a
call at 702
333 333-6666 and take advantage of their
special offer just mention channel 8
for a free one year home warranty with
home purchase
kendall